écoutez il est là il s'appelle bertrand
delorme le premier sosie nous vient de
marseille
il a 37 ans et c'est mickaël hanouna
regardez c'est mon sosie regarder
[Musique]
coderre comme ça parce que tu es
magnifique alley dénoncée par les bêtes
profond de bloquer ce que tu peux mais
ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
ah ouais frères sahraouis connais un le
n'est pas mal des plus beaux chants
[Musique]
marseille et je vais bien méritée et est
beaucoup plus beau que moi
non franchement à 6,6 juste dix ans -
c'est la dame a été trompé sur la fiche
aux attaques à l'afr 35 ça on est
abattus fait beaucoup plus
ah ouais quand même
mais était battre à ton avis on doit
avoir la même mère ou le même père koné
a reconnu le gâteau ou pas oui à la
mersey le même voilà merci
attention on a maintenant le sosie de
valérie bénaïm à l assistante de
direction du côté de sarcelles elle
maîtrise aussi bien le beau shing que
valérie regardez la elle est là sonia le
sol inovallée la veille
un bébé à la leur et elle a l'air aussi
sympathique que très belle et des choux
un jeu c'est de poser de de sophie
favier surtout grave
non c'est vrai elle est deux c'est
magnifique
ouais ouais j'adore vous êtes très belle
très cij à la haye facile et du coup ça
fait que moi aussi donc vous êtes
contente d'être le sosie de valérie
bénaïm très fier il ya déjà des gens
dans la rue qui vous ont dit ouais j'ai
souvent c'est vous et vous quoi bein je
connais bien puisque j'ai un resto
crainte du coup j'ai plus de prénom
c'est fini quoi tout le monde vous
appelle babau and we gonna renom de
suite c'est vous l'a déjà dit a way of
automatiquement oui on l'a déjà dit mais
donc maintenant c'est cyril tout le
monde ce n'est pas vrai et vous on vous
lit valérie ou par et on ne dissout pas
vraiment mais vraiment c'est incroyable
je fais de la télé mais aussi du coup je
fais la télé tu fais quoi
ben comme vous avez pas vous prendrait
sa place un jour vous inquiétez pas ça
variés et du coup ils vous parlent de
moi rapport à cirer jamais alors on a
maintenant le sosie de gilles verdez il
est aux brûlures il est auteur
compositeur sur paris il est moins
bruyant que gilles et s'appelle luc
regarder luc verdez
[Musique]
c est ce qu on vous prend pour cible
dans la rue la voix n'a rien à voir non
pas un petit peu j'ai mal à ma france
j'ai du mal à ma france la boîte ou
trois équipes ou ressemble mais c'est
magnifique c'est dingue mais aussi pour
moi de faire un jour sur deux
il ya qu'il ya quelque chose attention
on a maintenant le saisit de québec
kelly elle s'appelle mélissa elle a 21
ans à et puis j'ai quelques années alors
ne suis rien du tout cela une broutille
à cet âge là elle s'appelle mais lichaj
un papier mélissa bezo v10 regarder mes
dix années
[Musique]
ouais
etc
mais tu dois à côté mettez-vous à
caudiès pour kelly bout non pas du tout
acharné sr jamais vous a jamais prises
pour kenny a pourtant elles sont là
dedans ça vous êtes content non mais on
est franchement pour l'instant je trouve
ça fait pas mal et en plus je vais vous
dire la vérité pour la plupart les sodi
sont mieux clairet à la rédac et vous
mais vous l'avez trouvé où mais attendez
vous croyez que je suis dans la rue un
appel et puis elle nous a répondu merci
mes 10 ans 2 cas attention à ça alors là
sur la tête de ma mère
si on n'a pas un fou rire dans une mini
tube avec elle son fils d'isabelle la
halle à 57 ans elle s'appelle muriel lé
chauffeur livreur de pièces automobiles
à l'ats beat elbeuf elle est là
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voyez ça va mieux
franchement mettez-vous à côté est ce
qu'on appelle une fois oui non qu'est ce
que tu as dis pas que je vais faire
sombrer tous à il avait la possibilité
d'être le sosie de bruno le maire a
préféré la difficulté non arrêtez avec
ça je vous le demande
alors il a 29 ans assad m bien il est
fonctionnaire à paris il est
fonctionnaire pas il est très beau
presque attention comme j'ai un petit
peu tendance à coucher narcissique mais
si c'est la fanfare son parti je ne sais
rien demandé je ne sais pas contents
qu'on lui demande en direct écouter il
est là il s'appelle bertrand de leurs
maux
[Musique]
m
à
battu ceux de l'est et sept ans
voilà
on sait
[Musique]
oui ah bah allez vous lac lavable est
franchement à quoi y avait des serhani
fictifs je ne crois pas du tout à
l'heure du tout non le radar est planté
d'un laïc et planquera que le radar à
mon ami merci non mais incroyable et
berthon s'étaient déjà rencontrés oui
oui tout à fait salamon bertrand ouais
ça va bien c'est cuit pour bertrand
ouais pour combien tu fais de cette
fille par jour 0 mais on me dit souvent
que questeur toujours plaisir de
ressembler à matthieu delormeau waouf si
c'est franchement après enfin le pas des
bassins faut pas se le cacher c'est pas
dégueulasse mais bon vous préférez avoir
son physique ou son mental son physique
merci
[Musique]